all right a very very big week for the
David Pakman show the Joe Rogan
appearance a lot of other stuff so let's
go to the phones and see what's on
people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
let's start with our caller from the 205
area code who's calling today from 205
hey David this is uh this is Corey
welcome back from California thanks
Corey what's going on so when I watched
your interview I think it was for the
second time with about College
he pushed back about the trades and
emphasizing the trades more and not and
not being forum you know in particular
fully subsidizing let's say university
based education one of the things that
came to mind that I want to ask you for
a while is why not instead push for
fully funding trades maybe as a starting
point and then to expand let's say
towards subsidized or you know fully
subsidized university education well
what would be the reason to start with
trades I mean it's so you could start
anywhere or you could do both or you
could do neither but what would be the
reason to do trades first how would that
help us eventually get to subsidizing
fully subsidizing State College well I
think the thought would be at least in
my mind David would be that if you are
tackling what would be more in demand
right now so taking taking Andrews
concern let's say that that trades are
heavily under represented in the United
States versus many of the other European
countries in particular focusing on
trades first as a way to you know not
just get a better representation but
also start to mitigate some of the
incoming problems around automation and
how that might affect job opportunities
in the United States listen I don't know
that the automation
is going to be better handled by more
trade school versus more bachelor's
degrees I think that really the
fundamental question around automation
is going to be what portion of the gains
from automation go to the business
owners versus the employees and the way
to think about it would be imagine a
company with a hundred employees
automation makes it so that you you only
need 50 employees plus some machines to
get the same level of productivity
there's basically like three
possibilities for how those gains are
used in sort of like a purely vulture
capitalist system you would just lay off
the 50 employees you would keep only 50
and the company gets all of the gains of
that technology in a socialist system
you would keep all 100 employees and the
doubling of productivity from the
technology would allow every single
employee to just work half as much in
like a social democracy setting we would
say okay some portion of the gains from
that technology can go to the business
owner and then some portion should be
distributed among the employees and
where you set that line like is it five
percent or 95 percent for the employees
depends sort of on your political
philosophy I don't that's a reality
regardless I mean that's gonna happen in
both a program school jobs rather that
you need a bachelor's degree for and
jobs that you would go to trade school
for and I think it's just a broader
economic question I don't know that we
solve it more or less by saying we're
gonna focus on funding trade over
bachelor's degrees okay thanks for the
response all right great to hear from
you Cory appreciate it very much